buzz they coming to the mic talking
about the food they hate talking about
the food they like two fools gonna fight
but only taste buddies welcome to
t-a-s-t-e
i'm joe
and today we got all a beast battle a
beast battle today's wild broth
chick-fil-a versus chipotle yeah i go to
chick-fil-a get your
chick ready there's a lyric from us that
my buddy wrote right ready
i'll take a girl two to chick-fil-a and
get the chick to pay like i'm nick
lashay
my friend jim pigstone wrote that lyric
oh i like it it's a good lyric does nick
lachey often get people to pay for
because it was he wrote he wrote it when
he was married to jessica simpson and
jessica simpson was far more famous okay
all right
nothing against shout outs to cliche i'm
not knocking nicholas
but that was the joke
uh
i i often hear people say chipotle
you hear that no chipotle mayo chipotle
i think i was one of those people
chipotle yeah yeah i hear it a lot yeah
yeah look look
these are two titans in the end
industry
okay and by the way we're basing this
just on food let's please not get into
the politics of the whole thing
all right oh no we're talking gay
you don't think i'm bringing gays into
the chicken conversation
i know a lot of gay guys that'll eat
chick-fil-a i i do as well yeah i do as
well but you know all right okay let's
but you think our our voters online
aren't going to vote with their
with that in mind their wallets
with their taste are they going to vote
with their taste buds do you think
they're going to let politics come
chick-fil-a doesn't just want to murder
all the
jesus christ oh no
what is the i don't know what's the
what's the topic i honestly don't know
and i don't want to comment on it to to
avoid any potential
slanders remarks i feel like it's i was
gonna say murder the chickens
oh
oh boy
i don't know where you're going jesus i
know that they think what marriage is
should be between a man and a woman is
that what they think
i don't want to talk about it all right
well
they do marry delicious cutlets with
buns folks it is joe derosa from the
taste buds podcast please come see me
live i've got dates coming up in
philadelphia in march i'll be at the
south by southwest festival also in
march i'm also going to be at the creek
in the cave in may and then i will be in
fort myers at comedy fort in june and
then there's a bunch of other dates and
stuff coming up go to joederosainfo.com
so you can get all the information about
links to ticket sales and show times and
all that sort of thing and then joey
roses in nyc come out and see us we're
open
many days a week we're open for many
hours in those days and it's an awesome
bar social club hang out and we serve we
serve awesome awesome sandwiches so come
see us if you want the info and you're
in town joeyrosesnyc.com
what's up guys going to give you some
tour dates here albany and dc february
18th and february 19th still some
tickets left to that albany show there's
two shows uh madison and chicago
february 26 and february 27th i'll be at
the barrymore theatre and the vic
nashville lacrista stefano playing the
ryman on march 11th the next day i'll be
in chattanooga on march 12th i'll
reschedule reschedule burlington to may
13th also a rescheduled san diego in los
angeles i will be in san diego on may
25th in los angeles on may 22nd and then
the reschedule of foxwoods is june 25th
hey everybody i'm at the beacon theater
and i will be playing here on may 14
headlining doing stand-up tickets are on
sale right now at
savillcanocomedy.com
uh yeah just the building's beautiful
and i'm just touring it right now to see
the vibe but i'm thrilled um
and just come and watch your step
casting politics aside um
let's just i'm i'm arguing based on
merit and taste and menu okay
okay okay yeah chick-fil-a chick-fil-a i
undoubtedly hates chickens
chick-fil-a yeah yeah i'll give you this
as far as a chicken sandwich goes
especially grilled
chick-fil-a
does something with their chicken it's
juicy and succulent and it tastes great
and i think they are the best chicken
sandwich on forge
chick-fil-a menu is
terrible are you getting into the battle
already
i was going to launch right into it oh
well because we didn't do the chance yet
or anything all right all right i mean
what is this a free-for-all well we did
be 18 i'm gone for a couple weeks all
the rules go out the window
come on man all right all right
but do you have anything else you'd like
to maybe we get into a little history
before we start making 100 let's do it
let's get into the history chick-fil-a
i'm gonna guess came out in the 70s i
thought it came out during biblical
times
uh let's see the story behind
1967 1967 when we first opened our doors
our founder truett kathy that just
sounds like a hardcore but i've never
heard of first name christian doesn't it
yeah wanted a company that sounds like
the name of a guy that like comes back
and haunts after the cult died
like a poltergeist or something
have you ever heard the legend of truett
kathy
he hated chicken
he wanted the company's name to reflect
the top quality cust
to reflect the top quality customers
should expect each time they visited a
restaurant that's why he chose chick
filet
chick to represent the signature item
and filet
as a play on the word filet i mean are
they with a small twist they're
explaining this like we didn't know that
that's what filet mignon chicken fillet
yeah i mean this is they're really
breaking the stuff all right what year
now chipotle came out in
2019 i think don't get him don't get him
googling different things spelling
different things yet
we're just looking at history let's just
keep with a little chick-fil-a all right
how did chick-fil-a become so successful
chick-fil-a thrives because customers
value the pleasant dining experience
they've come to count on from the
restaurant an experience that likely
results from the top down corporate
culture of the company the fact that
their food consistently receives high
marks for the taste doesn't hurt though
it is crazy
business insider what is it is a very
pleasant dining experience so long as
you obey christ and follow his law
am i missing something did i not
chick-fil-a has a a
a different dining experience than any
anyone else i will say this about
chick-fil-a um i have gone through a
chick-fil-a drive-through several times
because i was living in la for a while
uh and and and also i grew up with chick
where i grew up chick-fil-a was like a
prominent
i didn't have chick-fil-a until a few
years ago yeah chick-fil-a was part of
the scene where i grew up so so i've
been through drive-throughs of
chick-fil-a i will say this always
always always and even when i've gone
into the counter
the most
pleasant
just just polite
it's it's clearly something that's
coming from the top down oh actually so
their workers are not like your typical
fast food workers right now they're very
like how are you doing like they smile
as if when you go into the disney store
in the mall
this is that with that i think yeah they
like
there is something about them trying to
feel you do feel that they're trying to
pull you in okay
uh but you know but yeah i will say that
it is it is incredibly incredibly
pleasant um i guess i've never dined in
a chick-fil-a and also had a chick-fil-a
at the detroit airport last week
oh man i would kill to have a
chick-fil-a access in an airport are you
kidding me go to detroit oh by the way
i'm going to detroit again i just came
from detroit i was in the detroit
airport last week three times in three
days and i never left the detroit
airport it was three layovers in three
days
why are you doing layovers
that's the only routing they had it was
like going to like des moines what are
you doing
can i can i give you some constructive
criticism please why don't you do this
to yourself
i gotta go i gotta go to these markets
and see you guys like four hit tv shows
your podcasts are doing well
why are you doing this live performance
babe yeah you stand up so maybe you do
some of the cities i'm in every guy i'm
not every i'm for every man i'm not
every man type of guy i don't go into
all the hard-to-reach places you guys
see the nightmare travel i have coming
up with tulsa and oklahoma city
oh buddy i don't get it minneapolis
milwaukee new york city may 14th
i i got a whole bunch of new dates
coming up syracuse rochester well those
aren't nightmare travel cities no but
i'm just saying that there's a whole
bunch of new cities about to be
announced players i'm saying all right
calm down all right i'm just saying why
do you do it to yourself treat yourself
treat yourself sal's defense most of
flights have gotten canceled these last
few weeks yeah canceled they're horrible
really i mean anything goes wrong i'm
out
why can't we fix it ticketing agent
looks at me sideways i get back in the
cab and go home
listen to me these are all these are all
to be announced too and i just found out
so i just want to say can we nice can we
please tell me please can i just say you
brought it up you brought it up i didn't
i'm trying to do a bit with you and now
you're plugging again stop you stop
opening dc shut up listen let me just
tell them what dates are coming up
yeah don't block jamie new york city may
14th and i that's
milwaukee minnesota memphis louisville
evansville tulsa oklahoma city rochester
syracuse knoxville greenville south
carolina hampton beach and mo this is
what people want to hear after they just
watched the commercial where you said
the same exact thing oh did oh i didn't
realize that one time thank you i told
you that last opportunity is in the air
today the negativity is in the air joe
derozan fine
info for all my upcoming dates and i'll
leave it at that i'll leave it at that
in my defense i didn't realize that we'd
be dropping something in because i just
i didn't realize really i think you
film on purpose every time that you say
we have to do this at the end
listen i i mean we put plugs in at the
end i put them in the beginning i want
people to know all the dates that are
about to be announced before i announce
it to everybody else get it dedicated
listener
all right
i don't get it about chick-fil-a
chick-fil-a's been out since 1967
chipotle came out in 2017. no it didn't
so you can't
you can't even compete that's why
mcdonald's
what is the history of chipotle chipotle
grill was founded by steve ellis in 93
and is based in denver colorado in 93
ellis took what he learned in san
francisco and opened the first chipotle
restaurant in denver near the university
of devon campus with 85 000 alone from
his father god bless the boy yeah uh
steve eastbrook the mcdonald's then ceo
said that investment in chipotle and the
other businesses were a distraction to
mcdonald's company executives wanted to
put 100 of their efforts to grow
mcdonald's brand thus they sold all the
shares so when did mcdonald's buy
chipotle
uh i think you know like you know in
like 2000 or something like that how
much did he make
but then they got rid of it i'll never
be able to see that
1995. scroll down
using cash flow ellis opened the second
chipotle in 95. third in 96.
father
scroll down
later that year ellis's father invested
another one and a half million
to fund further growth at chipotle and
he created a board of directors and
raised another 1.8 million okay
most notably mcdonald's invested
360 million dollars in chipotle in 1998
at the time chipotle was a five-year-old
company with just 16 locations in the
country with mcdonald's investment it
expanded to a footprint of 500 locations
by 2005. meanwhile mcdonald's became his
largest investor holding a 90 stake on
january 26 2006 chipotle went public
with a stock rising a hundred percent on
the first day the money raised from its
ipo was used to open more stores
mcdonald's suggested chipotle operate a
drive-through and add breakfast items to
their menus they also suggested a brand
name to chipotle fresh mexican grill in
order to compete with other mexican
chains such as baja fresh i actually
really like baja fresh i think baja
fresh is disgusting
and honestly it's it's it's it's one of
the few places
i refuse to eat at
i'm like i won't eat there i won't eat
there baja fresh why i think it's
disgusting i think it tastes like [ __ ]
well chipotle baja fresh
panera bread
i like panera bread not a fan
and a half sandwich in the soup nice and
then i kick it off with a pastry
sometimes they get i'll grab a banana i
don't care i i could i could with a gun
to my head i could eat
chicken
no i won't do it i won't do it so you
will be shot with a gun through your
head because you won't bite into a baja
fresh meal don't do it
just won't do it won't do it hate is
real folks yeah won't do it you'd rather
his black waffle house
and people get upset waffle house all
avoid at all costs waffle house is tough
it gives me such a stomach ache like i
just you know will you do dominoes
i mean dude i'm talking you you got to
be back to wall meaning like i didn't
eat at all today and literally the only
option is dominoes like and then it's
like what are you going to do you know
because it's two weeks should make it
joey rose's gun to head restaurant list
gun to my head yeah
uh chick-fil-a i was ripping them
because i think their menu is very
limited let's start do you want to start
the battle or not yes
well then start it the way it's supposed
to be started
[Music]
when i look into his eyes and i say it
something triggers in me and i actually
it takes a little bit of the edge off i
think ever since we started the channel
we haven't gotten into major brawls i
think the chant is keeping the people
from watching it really
after pool and beach and weed and
alcohol i know and and and and we do it
and it really i think has an effect
okay let you know that we're in the
octagon and what happens in the octagon
stays in the arm okay
so chick-fil-a is the premiere the gold
standard for a chicken sandwich fast
food it is everyone's favorite even
though they have a political stance that
all people don't agree with i like you
said before i even see people it doesn't
even matter they're like i just eat the
chick-fil-a and
well the reason i think that that's
justifiable by the way is because i
actually know a guy that owns a
chick-fil-a and he has said to me
it's a franchise he's like dude i don't
believe in that crap right he's like
it's a franchise he goes i own my
restaurant and i don't promote anything
okay fair so
i do think there is a justification to
being able to eat at this place without
you know what i mean okay um whereas
sometimes other stores like maybe you
know
we don't have to name names but there
are other places out there that aren't
franchises
that people might say i don't shop there
because of whatever sure you go okay
well that's a chain and it's all owned
by the same well we think this is gonna
be a big battle because like i said i
think that chick-fil-a is
i think in an island of its own as far
as like
a fast food restaurant it just has
chicken you can't touch it but i do
chipotle i think you got your other
competitors but i mean chipotle is the
is the gold standard for fast casual
mexican no no not even close not the
gold what is taco bell is the is the
stand for fast casual fast food mexican
taco bell
but pimp is almost choked on a salad i
watched him because you called taco bell
a gold standard we're talking about fast
food and mexican food once people think
fast food and mexican they think taco
bell they don't think chipotle first
they don't know i don't know about that
not these days i think chipotle has
carved out market share for itself man i
think you're looking at college kids and
i don't think when you say gold standard
chipotle the food is is much better than
taco bell outstanding it's got a higher
quality higher quality meats cuts of
meat fresher ones they make it right
there in front i'm just saying
if you're sitting around the house and
it's movie night and your your better
half or your best buddy or whoever
you're with says wanna get
delivery
oh wouldn't it be fun to get fast food
ooh let's get to you think you go
chipotle taco bell you're getting taco
bell come on give me a break i mean if
you hang in late night and you're like
playing video games or watching them i
don't know but but chipotle is the
better food it's better if there was a
shirt laying a taco bell next to each
other in an airport in a mall in a
parking and a park strip strip mall i'm
always going chipotle i get a taco bell
you're crazy bro but
let's
listen
back to the auditions
the biggest fast food chain that
competes directly against chipotle with
over 7 300 300 locations taco bell is a
giant that towers over chipotle waiting
for the right opportunity to grab its
market i mean i get i don't there it is
in plain text but you call it the gold
standard i'm talking about honestly for
quality it's not but you but but you
can't say that like here's the thing
for quality neither is chipotle then if
you're gonna look at it from that
standpoint there's a million
there's a million food though there's a
million taquerias and small food small
mexicans i know but that taqueria is
essentially fast food it's a chain fast
food fast casual restaurant the quality
of chipotle's food is
eons ahead i would say that you could
argue that you could argue you could
argue that chili's is is above uh
chipotle silly's is a restaurant chili's
has a has a strictly-to-go
fast food style thing attached to every
chili's a menu with everything on it
it's it's mexican i'm just telling you
something but here's what it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter we don't have
to i want to get back to your audacious
absurd argument that you were going to
make that chick-fil-a's menu is too
repetitive compared to chipotle it is
are you nuts
are you nuts well mexican food by design
is a lot of redundancies but so that's
why it's a crazy argument but
chick-fil-a the menu oh let me you know
what let me just wait till i get to
their fries because they're the worst
fries in the fast food game they are the
worst fries in the fast food game yeah i
said it
chick-fil-a's fries are not good bro
they're not good i don't know i don't
know they are they are they are good i
can't believe that they're competing
with the chicken sandwich at that higher
level and then they plummet with their
fry they don't plummet they're the only
ones doing waffle fries and the reason
and the reason is
oh they're always soft and undercooked
this is the guy that argued for [ __ ]
potato skins last week
right they're waffle fries and the
waffle fry complements their sandwich
their sandwich to me would be downgraded
if they didn't do
uh a a unique fragrance i need to have a
meeting about i need i would need the
guy in charge to call a meeting about
the fries i want to get him in there and
i want him to say look we're dominating
with chicken the person who's in charge
of fries corporately needs to be fired
this is why
family this is why chick-fil-a is better
this is why chick-fil-a is better cut it
as a waffle and think that's going to
solve all your problems this is fry is
horrendous this is why chick-fil-a is
better
why
you don't crave it's 30 different
chicken dishes
you crave that sandwich that's why it's
that simple you don't crave
chipotle oh you're wrong buddy and by
the way let me finish let me finish and
if you are craving chipotle you're
craving any burrito bowl of quality that
you can get in a million different
places when you crave chick-fil-a there
is one place that's going to satisfy
that hunger and it is chick-fil-a that
is it nobody can come close others have
tried mcdonald's has tried to mimic this
my sweet mcdonald's has tried to mimic
the sandwich and failed
the popeye sandwich is great but it
can't touch the chick-fil-a sandwich kfc
has great chicken sandwiches they can't
touch the chick-fil-a how are you going
to say that when people are craving
chipotle they're actually
craving any type of mexican restaurant
you tell me you tell me if i get you a
really nice grilled chicken sandwich
from a restaurant
i don't know who's getting grilled
chicken at chick-fil-a i'm getting the
original chick-fil-a sandwich with the
two pickles in the breaded patty number
one yes you cannot get that that taste
anywhere except chick-fil-a you know it
what are they doing to the children i
don't know i don't know
but you know that that's true well
you're craving a specific taste i guess
every time you you don't guess every
time you get that chicken sandwich from
a restaurant over that chicken please
that's so nuts
every chick-fil-a sandwich every time
perfectly moist it's never dry perfect
layer of
a patented hydraulic system that exerts
the perfect amount of pressure on the
chicken the fast food joint was able to
achieve a juicy and tender piece of meat
that cooks quickly and produces arguably
the most emblematic indicator of freshly
cooked meat real grill marks
here's the thing too here's the thing
too with chick-fil-a it's never oh it's
never done incorrectly
it's consistent
and you want to talk about flavor and
whatever they put two pickles on that
thing and that's it you're out the door
that roll they use i don't know if it's
buttered or what is going on with it but
it's amazing
now you tell me chipotle what
aside from the fact that it's fresh
ingredients
and like a quality meat you're sitting
there what stands out there right now
what stands out about what you taste
right in front of you i don't care what
stands out about the taste of it
i think the taste is very very good for
fast food yeah okay but my point is it's
good the beef is good
blackened chicken they've got a pico de
gallo in there yeah yeah i love the
beans they got a good variety of beans
all of these things at any decent bowl
is unbelievable i eat a burrito bowl i
feel like i'm i'm getting my money's
worth it weighs about two pounds great
it has it has fresh ingredients it fills
me up and it doesn't doesn't still
haven't answered my question it doesn't
feel like i'm eating trash food still
neither chick-fil-a but you still
haven't answered my question
you everything you're describing about
the burrito bowl is consistent with
almost any quality place where you can
get a burrito
no it's not yes it is no no you cannot
emulate chick-fil-a's flavor
brother you're you're way out of your
league here you're wrong i'm out of my
league you're wrong all right do you
think that people are more there are
more die-hard people for chipotle or
die-hard people with chick-fil-a i think
chick-fil-a obviously like because i
think it's a unique experience that you
can only get there
chick-fil-a if you want chicken you go
there otherwise they have nothing to
offer you that's not what i'm saying
you're not you're dodging the question
because you don't have an argument not a
chicken sandwich you're talking about
chicken no i'm saying that's a hole when
you want that signature dish which is
their original chicken chicken bread
signature dish just like yeah a burrito
bowl signature dish i didn't call it a
signature dish that's but that's that's
chipotle's signature dish is the burrito
bowl that's what they're known for
that's their thing that's what everybody
gets when they go there okay i've never
seen somebody go and get the tacos at
[ __ ] chipotle nobody wants the tacos
for them for tacos all day long anyway
okay great my point is this
you cannot tell me why
chipotle is a unique experience taste
wise versus why i can tell you
chick-fil-a is a unique experience taste
wise
i thought the bottom line though is
chick-fil-a falls under the category of
your really standard fast food item
whereas the olay is known as elevated it
is it is it's a lot more real
ingredients fresher ingredients made
right in front of you whole piece of
chicken breast meat
whole piece of chicken breast but it is
unbelievably seasoned on a nice on a
nice roll with two pickles what is what
is processing i think about that i think
europe i think chick-fil-a is more um
more uh
fast food whereas
i heard you the first 11 times you said
it but you know there's drive-throughs
in chipotle
you get a good burrito bowl from
chipotle how is that unique in flavor
and taste to any place you get a good
burrito bowl from it's accessible it's
high quality at a decent price point
what do you mean i don't get it i mean
everywhere what would i do you get your
burrito bowls man where cadoba boom okay
yeah kedoba exactly chick-fil-a
exactly the same thing okay but but
it's not as good neither is it it's not
fresh no it's not yes it is you just
said it wait so you're just comparing it
to one other fast food place and saying
it's your typical brutal i'm saying any
place i have ever gone of of decent
quality that sells a burrito bowl if you
put me in a blind taste test with that
against chipotle i could not tell you
the difference however if you put me in
a blind taste test chick-fil-a versus a
million other chicken sandwiches i know
the chick-fil-a every time and when i
crave it there is no substitute because
there is a certain taste you got pickles
on it you got the the all right fine
that's fine but you're telling me thank
you for finally admitting to that but
it's just because it has a distinct
taste doesn't mean that chick-fil-a as a
whole we're arguing chick-fil-a as an
institution versus chipotle as an
institution you're leaning into the fact
that you love the way one chicken
sandwich tastes but you're you're just
neglecting the entire
because their rice also tastes like
somebody else's rice it doesn't make any
sense
or
pimples it has a reputation but i want
you to get a reputation for fast casual
very everyone thinks no one you never
hear people complain about the quality
of chipotle you as a matter of fact you
only hear people pat them on the back
for it it's it's it is fresh quality
ingredients in a fast casual restaurant
kanye west says a song about chick-fil-a
yeah yeah and it's a hit that's a hit
too which one is this
what song it's called
chick-fil-a is closed on sunday yeah
what about that chick-fil-a is closed on
sunday an observance of religion
yeah that's wild yeah they didn't say it
wasn't what's that gonna do with the
food
what's it gonna do with this
what about what about your your son it's
a sunday and you're dying for your
chick-fil-a you can't get it because in
jerusalem a couple of thousand years ago
something happened
what's your point my point is joey
rose's why were you losing church and
joey rose's clothes on a monday night
while we mentioned and are those people
happy on that wednesday while we mention
yeah you're close be it closed because
the same reason other businesses are
closed usually monday is a slower day it
doesn't pay to open it's a different
they close an observance
yeah of a being a spiritual being
okay i don't care i love you
why are we mixing chicken and chicken
and church we already talked we already
talked about this it doesn't affect the
quality of the food you're telling me a
guy that franchises like your friend
can't open on that day he can't feed his
family on a weekend day
i'm sure on a weekend is where a lot of
the fast food sales are up right people
are out they're going shopping they're
in you know this isn't an argument about
the food though you're making it's it's
about both restaurants so if chick-fil-a
stands by being closed on sundays
i'll tell you this brother what about
your friends
your friend
doesn't believe in it has to lock his
doors and i can't walk his kids want to
go to college i can't i can't i can't
tell you the last time i passed a
chick-fil-a and didn't go in to get
something that's how much i love it i
[Music]
that's you that's why i'm arguing it i
know that's me that's the point of the
show because i argued the thing i like
10 years filming jokers a lot of times
in the middle of the day we're starving
we're filming all day we're like [ __ ]
let's afford something fast i'm talking
50 people on that crew
10 out of 10 times we're going chipotle
over chick-fil-a 10 out of 10 9 out of
10 times okay
people i would agree with people like oh
chipotle today and i'm like yes chipotle
today people do
i would no i think that it's a quality
food that tastes good i'm not saying
that it's not when i worked in writers
rooms i liked chipotle as an option too
why it was a decently healthy meal it
didn't make me feel tired afterwards
great if i didn't get it with the rice
doesn't mean it's a better food why not
by the way it's secret it's exciting
chipotle's secretly fattening really
yeah by the way it's horribly
look at the calorie count of chips and
guacamole i'm not getting chips in guac
bro it doesn't matter it's secretly fat
all right we're going to do that every
menu has already looked up
the uh
yeah but you want to look up both menus
pimp i just want to i want to leave but
i'm not making the argument for health
you are no
no i didn't yes you are you're making a
quality argument yeah quality is better
yes it is healthier you're right okay
let's look at the calorie count but i'm
not saying you can't pick off one item
on the menu that's going to be high in
fat guacamole is pure fat pimp just to
put chipotle burrito bowl calories let's
just see what the average calories but
i'll just look up your your fried
chicken sandwich calories i'm not
arguing that it's that it's better for
you and it's this but you're picking one
thing on the menu that you think has
high in calorie and fat then what i'm
talking about overall
i offered the other item which was the
chips
and you said i don't eat that so i'm
going to the thing that you do chicken
from chick-fil-a and i raise you beef i
raise you [ __ ] tofu okay i raise you
uh uh a steak okay plus i got rice i got
beans i got
you something right
it'll be a come on i got so much more
totally fresh food than you it'll be
these
it'll be a cold day in tijuana when i
can tell the difference between the
steak the pork or the chicken at
chipotle you're nuts it all tastes the
same they can't tell the difference
between steak and pork not a chipotle i
can't oh that's your problem
on south side i can get a beer in
chipotle
how about that because it's fast
casually
you know what i can get you know what i
can get a chick-fil-a
homemade lemonade
homemade lemonade
nothing beats you in my face
joe you realize that everything you're
eating is frozen right everything
not what do you think is happening at
chipotle do you think they're
slaughtering lambs in the background
they're cooking it on the grill they're
oh yeah i'm sure they're chopping it all
up let's look it up i'm sure they're
chopping it up i want to look at two
things i want to look at both menus and
i want to look at both manufacturing
processes and you're right by the way
you're right by the way it's there's
nothing like the attractiveness of that
when you're ordering food watching stuff
get scooped out of that
we try to focus
hey right there first one first one is
chick-fil-a fresh or frozen chick-fil-a
which last year surpassed kfc whoa to
become the number one chicken in the u.s
is touted as home of the original
chicken sandwich the chicken it serves
is fresh never frozen and it's hand
breaded in the restaurants suck my dick
let's go to chipotle
let's go to chipotle you didn't even
know it show you just found out so get
off your [ __ ] horse
just found out chipotle seeks out the
finest ingredients that are not only
fresh but their raised responsibility
responsibly with respect for animals
land and the people who produce them
chipotle prepares its food without the
use of added colors flavors or
preservatives typically fast food i love
chipotle is fresher and better and it's
terrifically the animals are humanely
raised
they're worried typically let me let me
let me google chicken
chick-fil-a chicken farm it's gonna be
coops that you don't even want to look
at chipotle's website says it's fresh
cooking is done using plastic
no shortcuts but chipotle doesn't do all
its own cooking
go ahead read it up read it two outside
companies braise the carnitas in the
barbacoa trim the steaks and cook the
beans what it's about it's still fresh
oh my god this is from an article called
nine disappointing facts oh let's go
through this article who's got an alpha
chipotle if you're going to pull that up
you pull up disappointing
we go through them both because i have
had this this is a [ __ ] hit job right
now the company that does chipotle's
cooking is the same one that makes
mcdonald's mcnuggets big macs mcribs
chipotle does not do its own cooking
okay
what's going on the point number two
it does too said it does most of its own
cooking don't lie some of chipotle's
locally sourced food travels thousands
of extra miles so it can be processed in
chicago some of chipotle's locally
sourced food travel
for some reason it says it's place
chipotle animal welfare standards may be
better than other national restaurant
chains but they are still unclear
chipotle's animal
okay sorry
chipotle is importing grass-fed beef
from australia despite american
producers lining up to work for them so
they don't care about the americans
chipotle will not disclose which
australian companies are supplying its
grass-fed beef so basically they're the
netflix of fast food
we had the highest rated whatever can we
see the numbers nope
i mean i'm gonna pull up the same thing
with chicken okay let's i can't wait i
can't wait chipotle's ingredients
include gmos and trans fats
chipotle's advertising campaigns are as
much fiction as facts who wrote this
what does that even mean
what does that even mean oh oh here's
the nail in the coffin the restaurant's
cultivating thought campaign features
the work of 10 writers none of them
mexican or latino oh my god who made
this article
who wrote this article colonel sanders
you're chipotle ceos are paid a combined
49.5 million while the average
entry-level employee is 21 000.
this is [ __ ] good what does it
matter i'm talking about the food man
all right let's go to let's find
disappointing facts about chick-fil-a
this winter
i want you sal to upgrade your daily
routine with bespoke post
and their new seasonal lineup of
must-have box of awesome collections we
got some of this stuff and it's really
cool i got it yeah bespoke post partners
with small businesses and emerging
brands and they bring you unique goods
every month uh i have used them twice so
far i think i mentioned this one time i
got a garment bag that also falls into
it like to
goes into a duffel bag yeah so i like
that uh i never had a garment bag before
but it's not just strictly a garment bag
so i get used out of it all the time
it's really cool uh it's good quality
and they i also
got a machete bro
i've always a machete no hunting knife
it's a it's a it's a machete you got a
machete it's like that oh wow you got a
really cool hunting how big is the knife
it looks like a rambo
oh so no that i didn't get that i got a
straight up machete that you can go
through you like and cut stuff down with
like i love it i always wanted a machete
and it's cool it's like it's in like a
leather attache i love it it's got a
cool handle yeah i'm like oh i'm gonna
keep this also in the house well here's
the thing whatever you're into box of
awesome has you covered yeah sent me
amazing whiskey glasses uh i got a oh
you got the whiskey stones for the for
the drinks uh i didn't get the stones i
got whiskey glasses that have a pointed
bottom and are spill proof and they say
oh i like that so cool um but they just
have so much cool stuff to get started
you're going to go take a quick quiz at
box of awesome.com your answers will
help them pick the right box of awesome
free curated for you
exactly they release new boxes every
month
across a ton of different categories by
the way what an awesome gift
for like stuff in there from yeah
from shoes to gloves to knives to
cookware to barbecue stuff to travel
stuff exactly lotions cologne like it's
ever it's everything you're getting all
kinds of cool stuff and then also you're
supporting small businesses i mean this
is so great that ninety percent of
everything that comes in the box of
austin awesome is from a small
up-and-coming brand so and it retails
for about 45 this is a good good part
though it retails for like 45 but the
actual if you buy the things
individually in the box it's like 75
bucks so you're getting almost a savings
of like half off and it gets even better
because you're gonna get 20 off your
first monthly box when you sign up
at box of awesome.com enter the code
tastebuds at checkout that's box of dot
com code taste buds for 20 off your
first box
buddy i got good news for you or
interesting news i've sort of uh i've
switched off the old ziggy's
i know which is why i want to talk about
lucy yep yep lucy is the nicotine
alternative yeah you're going to consume
nicotine to relax you might as well
consume it in a way that's yeah not as
bad as cigarettes that's for sure has
helped me make the switch i like what
they do i like their product they got a
gum they got a little pouch you park and
uh it's helped me make a switch from
ciggies and i'll tell you i've been
quite drunk at times and still not
switched back to siggies i noticed you
don't smell like a barn either yeah when
i have the craving i pop a loose and
that's it yeah
all right okay yeah and look a lot of
people use nicotine to relax focus or
just unwind lucy is a modern oral
nicotine company that makes the gum and
lozenges and the pouches for adults who
are looking for a responsible way to
consume their nicotine uh it's a new
year why not start out by switching to a
new nicotine product that you can feel
good about okay yeah and it's nice too
like i like that they have these little
packets and and there's a there's a
method to the way you chew the gum you
don't just chew it you kind of park it
then chew it and park it and chew it and
honestly for a guy like me who sits at a
computer and writes or whatever
it sort of gives you a ritualistic
aspect to it like you would have with
smoking so if you enjoy using nicotine
you should definitely check out lucy's
products at lucy.co that's
use the promo code tastebuds at checkout
also
uh i have to read this uh warning the
product does contain nicotine nicotine
is an addictive chemical remember if
you're interested though and a better
way to use nicotine visit lucy.co and be
sure to use that promo code
taste buds
chick-fil-a toxic
employees push way too hard chick-fil-a
is unbelievably toxic place to work all
upper management is trained to work
regular team members as hard as they can
because turnover rates are so high in
the fast food industry
all right there's not really any basis
for those who don't unhealthy cook that
one
these items are very high in sugar fat
and calories uh they may not be your
best choices consider only eating them
on occasion
if you're watching sugar fat and calorie
intake go ahead okay that's that's a
no-brainer we all know that is
chick-fil-a healthy not seeing
disappointing facts about chick-fil-a
just go to no but go to go to one of the
again this picture has they're super
disappointed and sh there's a whole
bunch of [ __ ] no but this is these are
opinion blocks
these are like
uh these are like reddit threads don't
find it just she's scrolling too fast
let's see disappointing is one word not
often associated with chick-fil-a
oh look at that a vat of nuggets
disappointing is one word that's not
often associated with chick-fil-a
uh
the chain is known for going above and
beyond for customers on countless
occasions okay there was a chick-fil-a
in texas that helped out a teacher
working in new mexico who forgot her
purse by not only overnighting it back
to her but also adding a gift card
they knew that was a pr stunt
picture worth a thousand words okay okay
let's see people have some choice words
for chick-fil-a especially those worried
about food waste an image posted on
reddit features chick-fil-a leftovers
and a note all of this is trashed the
image shows two shells full of various
chicken chicken nuggets and other items
that seem to be ready to be thrown away
okay so somebody on reddit posted a
picture and made a claim and we have no
idea if it's true or not also food we're
gonna get we're gonna get into food
waste every restaurant does that so
check out pimpy and it sucks when any
restaurant does it's criticisms of
chick-fil-a
oh you're flailing dude
oh you this is one i wish they could
have heard the
no that's not even criticisms but
critic there
oh boy you got it there it is
chick-fil-a's anti-lgbt controversy
okay yeah we where else
that you can't even fact check
chick-fil-a
no chick-fil-a has not resumed donations
to groups that oppose lgbtq right oh wow
another point for chick-fil-a what do
you mean it says they have not re they
have not returned to making those
donations they stopped doing they
dropped no no you're wrong that's what
it just said no no ending
has not resumed donations to the groups
that oppose the rights of gay people it
says it right there
they did the right thing
it's their stance though
no it's the fact that they were donating
to certain groups that opposed lgbtq
rights okay
yeah so another as i said another point
for chick-fil-a nah
i would really like to well after this i
just want to look on uh
gay marriage oh beef i get it
uh
okay scroll scroll it's see oh
when you put criticism is going to be
the lgbt
no it's always going to come because it
couldn't just be that your restaurant's
full of [ __ ] and buddy we just clicked
on the first three pages here best and
worst i mean everything's about lgbtq
what am i going to do
no you saw we you saw unhealthy uh we're
throwing this this this picture why does
chick-fil-a make me sick you can get
food poisoning chick-fil-a food
poisoning reports commonly include
diarrhea and nausea symptoms salmonella
is common
this is just scroll down more brilliant
all the way more and more okay more you
right there scroll up you should never
eat at chick-fil-a again from mashed.com
the cows might be telling us to eat more
chicken but does it really have to be a
chick-fil-a chicken the company
according to ranked number eight overall
in the u.s for fast food sales in 2018
already out earns mcdonald's
okay so here we go there's also the food
to consider and they're saying outside
of the political views cfa zealots will
say that the chains chicken sandwiches
are tops but we're not so sure it turns
out the sandwich isn't even the most
popular item
what happened
uh oh most probably item on their own
menu in fact for two years running the
waffle fries have claimed the title and
we think we know why although hardcore
fans might disagree these are the
reasons you should never eat chick-fil-a
again number one the sandwiches are
super salty that's true don't give a
[ __ ] tastes great
uh and they still aren't that good
that's not true and that's that's that's
subjective so whatever the sauce just
complicates things that's not a real
argument nobody cares that's for the
nuggets the fries aren't that great okay
whatever the history of the employee
discrimination okay now let's see what
this says
the corporate purpose listed on the
company's website reads to glorify god
by being a faithful steward of all that
is entrusted to us and have a positive
influence on all who come into contact
with chick-fil-a given that one might
assume that discriminating against
employees whether it be due to gender
disability or other reasons will be off
the table but their track record
suggests otherwise according to forbes
the company was sued at least 12 times
between 98 and 2007 on charges no no no
no
1988 and 2007 no you said 98.
okay
well there's that's a huge difference
one former muslim employee alleges he
was fired after refusing to participate
in group prayer to jesus christ
2011 chick-fil-a had a lawsuit brought
against of agenda discrimination more
recently the company was against accused
of discriminations this time against
disabled job applicants after an
autistic man tried to apply for a job
the 2016 lawsuit alleges that the
manager told the applicant's job coach
that chick-fil-a was not interested in
hiring people with disabilities and
people with disabilities would not be
able to succeed at a chick-fil-a
is there any proof to any of this all
right fair enough you know what i mean
yeah this is all and also as we said
this is a franchise restaurant it could
have been an [ __ ] that owned a
chick-fil-a in the middle of nowhere
that yeah we're not trying to get into
this big this big house the part i clip
and tag both companies
all right let's go
we actually got to go reading what's
coming up yeah i know we got to go to
the phones we got to go to the phones
where are we pimpy we gotta go to the
phones
okay okay don't contradict me i i know i
just wanna know where we are i can't ask
him where we are i have your best
interest in mind
14 000 votes okay let's double the last
amount of votes read a few questions
chipotle isn't my favorite mexican spot
but if i'm gonna get diarrhea i'm gonna
get do it for a burrito quesadilla or
burrito how about this how about the uh
the level of look at me please look at
me please
we don't have to go anywhere we do i
wanna just say a couple days what about
the fact that what about the
customization in chipotle how you have
everything in front of you and you can
make it to your liking you could put as
much you could double this leave out
this use this you could you could make
it here exactly to your specifications
so you can go in there and really
whatever you're in the mood for they
will make it yeah you will run your
thing i'll tell you what why don't i
bring my own chicken and i'll get behind
the grill cooking
myself i just wanna read you here i just
wanna i don't care it's not a menu
chicken sandwich chicken sandwich
chicken sandwich oh that's not true
chicken nuggets
chicken salad
chicken grilled chicken salad
chicken sandwich it's like what are we
doing here yeah they do they do they
specialize in one thing and they make a
grand slam hit out of it there's a
sausage egg and cheese biscuit for
breakfast there's a bacon egg and cheese
biscuit there's a chicken egg and cheese
biscuit there's a a hash browns uh
scramble bowl there's a hash ground
scrambled burrito i mean there's
breakfast there's salad well but stop
saying that the menu is all the same
there's a chicken salad wrap there's
actual salad but it's it's just chicken
chicken chicken you gotta go chicken
chicken you're flailing here it's
embarrassing how am i flailing bro
all right ready
let's talk about green shad green chef
what is it green chef
it's a ccof certified meal kit company
green chef is making eating well easy
with plans that fit every lifestyle
whether you're keto paleo vegan
vegetarian gluten free or just looking
to eat more balanced meals green chef
offers a range of recipes to suit you
and your preferences and you know look
we talk about meal kits on this show one
thing that green chef is doing that i
think is very very cool is that they are
targeting specific lifestyle dietary
preferences that's very cool that they
say are you paleo are you keto are you
yes i like so when they joined on we get
to try it out and i ordered my first one
and i picked the carb conscious it
should be here any day okay would you
order because i saw that you ordered two
i think i ordered also i think i also
ordered carb conscious i think that was
and there was another one that was
called like eat well so i i like either
that or carb content whether you're
looking for carb conscious or
gluten-free plant-based or calorie
conscious options
or you just want to have delicious
balanced dishes green chef has flavorful
good food uh recipes that are sure to
satisfy as the first ever and only keto
meal kit on the market green chef makes
sticking to a carb conscious lifestyle
easy enjoy your greens while being green
also green chef is the most sustainable
meal kit offsetting 100 of their plastic
packaging in every box and 100 of their
carbon footprint and emissions that's
actually very important to me you know i
don't i don't uh
see this thing i got this because i took
uh a car service home but like 10 years
ago i stopped buying plastic bottles
it's that's what's very uh useful it's
problematic it is it's
i agree so i like that they do that go
to greenchef.com
tastebuds130 and use code tastebuds130
to get 130
off plus free shipping that's a heck of
a deal folks green chef dot com slash
taste buds 130 and use code tastebuds130
to get 130 off plus free
shipping
so talk to me about
you know what about
about athletic greens i love athletic
greens i've been taking them for years
um they are now a partner on the website
i started taking athletic greens
probably about two three years ago uh my
lady introduced me to him and
we did she did a lot of research
actually and it turned out that this was
like one of the the the highest quality
okay uh
places it's really a i take it for the
vitamins but it supports good probiotics
gut health and things like that and
that's my favorite thing is the gut
health gut health is something that's
very very
sort of dis discarded like an
overlapping that's that's true i believe
it is incredibly important digestive
issues digest feeling bloated all these
things can be what i do is i uh
every morning before i leave the house
to go to work i make myself i just shake
it up
put a scoop in shake it up in the bottle
and take it with me and you play the
song shake it up by the car check it out
dance all night yeah do the hurricane
journey
uh and i take it with me and i drink it
along my commute that's what i love the
taste of it too that's another thing it
doesn't taste like the earth and that's
one of the things i like about athletic
greens is it's designed to benefit your
lifestyle it's sort of an on-the-go
thing or if you want to sit home while
you drink it you could do that too one
scoop has 75 high-quality vitamins
minerals uh superfoods probiotics and
adaptogens and this is something you can
toss right into your carry-on bag if
you're traveling or whatever else it is
so it helps again keep with the
lifestyle uh consistency that we all
need the travel and all these things
break up consistency with the diet and
with the healthy routine helps support
better sleep quality and recovery which
is awesome it's less than a gram gram of
sugar which is if by the way if you like
fresh fresh juices and you like green
juice a lot of times those are loaded
with like
apple it there's a lot of sugar in it
this is less than a gram of sugar it's
like 50 calories i think a serving costs
less than three dollars a day if you go
into these
high-end juice places that are all over
the place now and these juice bars and
[ __ ] you're paying nine dollars for a
fresh-squeezed juice to get the same
thing uh or less quite frankly uh your
subscription comes with a year's supply
of vitamin d which is so important to
add in this in these winter months when
you don't get as much sunlight and
athletic green says over seven thousand
five star reviews you sold me boys you
sold me right now it's time to reclaim
your health and arm your immune system
with convenient daily nutrition
especially heading into the flu and cold
season it's just one scoop and a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills and supplements
to look out for your health which is
also what i did i made it replace my uh
my daily all right let's take that again
because the doorbell rang okay
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and your
right now it's time to reclaim your
health and arm your immune system with
convenient daily nutrition especially
heading into the fluent cold season
one scoop just one scoop and a cup of
water every day that's it no need for a
million different pills supplements to
look out for your health this is all you
need and to make it easy athletic greens
is gonna give you a free one year supply
of immune supporting vitamin d and five
free travel packs with your first person
first purchase all you have to do is
visit athleticgreens.com
taste buds
again that is athleticgreens.com
tastebuds to take ownership over your
health and pick up the ultimate daily
nutritional insurance
i love chipotle but the quality of food
has gone downhill i'm never satisfied
with what i order anymore chick-fil-a is
so good it makes me go against my own
morals
i hate that i love it
this isn't even close for me i've only
had chick-fil-a a single time but it's a
million times better than anything i've
been into oh wow okay here there
first off god bless oh hey there sorry
just first off god bless secondly
chipotle tastes like they purposely put
sour cream in the freezer so absolutely
nothing is hot in the 15 seconds it
takes to sit down god bless
you want to read some of these
hold on hold on hold on let me see
all right first of all papa
no need for a second so i'm going
chipotle chick-fil-a is the vanilla ice
of fried chicken
i never had chick-fil-a so sad uh as a
small town canadian canada doesn't
happen chipotle's hit or miss
chick-fil-a is at least consistent
chipotle offers more variety both in
food it offers and the sexuality allows
these customers to have
that's very funny
oh scroll up
yeah it's it's okay yeah we know this
they are pick oh jeez like they're like
that's a contender
uh i just know chipotle makes south
tummy hurt chick-fil-a is overrated
chipotle because at least i get my
salmonella on sunday boom boom boom
chick-fil-a and only chick-fil-a only
tastes good because of the sauce
tastes so microwaved now chipotle that's
nirvana right there with every bite an
angel gets its wings and kids wishes
come true
this is a hard one when they're both
when they're both at their best i do
have to say i find chick-fil-a's quality
to be much more consistent across
locations with time over time chipotle
could easily come across a bad day or
location all right one more on taste
only cfa is like mcds i know exactly
what i get and it's the it when i get it
and the spicy sandwich only one that
really burns chipotle's delish unless
you get rotten lettuce or e coli google
each out
google each an outbreak 25 million
chipotle sentiment over e coli uh
diarrhea etc see if uh chick-fil-a nada
no no lawsuits for food poisoning all
right let's give it to the the sexuality
one or the
sure that was that all made us
laugh that right there you just passed
it okay follow at j-a-y-s-o-r-r-e-x
we've already plugged
let's just
what do you think's gonna happen uh i'm
not sure to be honest well i think that
you are going to win because i think
chick-fil-a probably has
you know 10 times more sales you've got
more locations than chipotle but no did
you see how many people said that's not
they don't chick-fil-a in canada
okay you know i don't know well
here we go okay we got 2 000 votes yeah
14 000 votes this is the humble pie
segment let's get a drum roll pimpy get
that graphic in here what is the
percentage of pimp chip picking chipotle
oh wow
handily chick-fil-a wins handily here
62
to 38 at the 14 200 votes so far
that that is a clear-cut winner i did
believe that uh in the end it was gonna
win when we started looking up the
statistics that they have more sales
than mcdonald's and and past kfc and
chipotle is not as big as a as an
operation but uh man i thought mexican
food would take a chicken sandwich i
really did i'm behind you i'm creeping
up dude you have two wins in a row now
i'm creeping back up
i still love you i love you too
they coming to the mic talking about the
food they hate talking about the food
they like two fools gonna fight but only
one food can be right